I spent a lot of time in my 20s waiting
for someone to tell me that it was my
time and expecting someone to say okay
I'm gonna step aside and now it's your
turn and that's not a thing so you need
to make your own time and take your own
turn mistakes are okay as long as they
don't kill you
things change so live your life in
chapters don't compare yourself to other
people realize that you don't know what
people are going through so don't think
that everyone is better than you I would
tell myself that I deserve good things I
deserve to be loved and happy and have
people in my life who like me for all my
weird quirks if I had known that I would
be the person that I am today without
them I would have left a long time ago
that is when I really learned that it is
okay to be selfish one stopped playing
piano just because you found another
passion YouTube essence keep too many
passes it's important to realize that
everybody is human and has limited
experiences no one is an authority you
know better than anyone what's best for
you it is completely okay to be weird I
have been very accustomed to being the
odd one out and it led me to the best
things possible you feel it in your
heart and you believe that it's right
lean into it don't try to change
yourself for other people your curls are
amazing